without further ado
i'm gonna be calling for the right here
in the bullpen hey jj
come on come on come aboard bud come
aboard buddy
um i do believe that we're gonna need
ourselves a uh
we're gonna be we're gonna be needing
we're gonna be needing the
i'm taking my my my talents to
stonerville
hey jj what's up buddy oh
very happy about this we we were
actually playing valheim yesterday just
talking about how fun today was going to
be
you and me both you and me both i i've
actually really enjoyed you being on it
it's been a lot of fun
it really has been it's feels like the
old mlr days
um we're getting there why am i hearing
myself back where's your ship over
it's not me what it's not me nothing has
changed on my end
oh okay it's gone now it was a gremlin
all right it was a
[ __ ] gay door for whatever was it the
sexy gremlin from gremlins 2
no it was one of them gay dwarfs that we
fight in the game that we play
yeah with your cheating sword then now i
have one i have one too
hey you have a cheat sword there has to
be in-game rewards or there's no reason
to play the game
look i i agree with you uh
it breaks everything though um so
do we want to start what order do we
want to do this sit
well i mean i think the people have to
know
what's going on i think we could do the
old
you know if you want to start off a
little bit and build up to it or we
could just be like hey guys this is what
we're doing
it's up to you man okay so let's let's
do this so so you remember
adrosti and a lot of people like oh man
look what you're doing to her oh can you
believe it can you believe what you're
doing or her what you're doing to her is
so wrong
oh my god why are you being so mean to
this lady
turns out turns out that this was always
about
and shout out to the [ __ ] million
dollar man ted dibiase
um this was always
always about the money well let's just
play this and then we'll
play what happened hold on because her
audio is always terrible
jj stoner hey all about the money
we can teach you how to make money but
you want to rant and play victim
it was explained if you go back to
pokemon
we'd move on but here we are
i i know she revenge
it was explained huh it was explained
hey then if i just go back okay let me
try
and don't speak out about my life
anymore you'll stop harassing me
it was explained to me that i can't
defend myself against your blatant
lies now some context here
i posted a a comment on her page
saying like look i'm done talking about
you i'll never talk about you again
there's one caveat no talk about me or i
will defend myself
i'm done i'm not talking to you we're
done and i really meant that that wasn't
a bit or anything and i you guys changed
you talked about it off here i'm like
i'm going to talk about him or [ __ ] her
then
dude i look before we even did yesterday
i was like dude
i completely understand if you want to
hit the ejector seat i get it
and here we are so
uh i said that and um she
said this on his channel saying he's not
making money off of me while the live
chats are scrolling above his head
and he is actively making money
off of me yes i am going to point that
[ __ ] [ __ ] out because it's
absolute [ __ ] to have him sitting
there
with live chat scrolling above his head
and hear the words coming out of his
mouth saying
i'm not making money off of this the
[ __ ] live chat
am hey rory she's mad she should
probably calm down a little bit
yeah she should take a deep breath and
you know run her hair
you know hand through her hair oh that's
the thing
awesome hey shout out to adonis paul by
the way well adonis paul's right adraste
is a is all elite now
on your video say that you are making
money off of it [ __ ]
and i can go to your [ __ ] video and
show you that day wave is one word when
you're searching for it next time
wanna [ __ ] watch yourself saying
you're not making money
while you're making money oh [ __ ] she
pulled out the headphones
oh boy here we go here we go y'all see
the [ __ ] super chat going across the
screen right now
hey some of those are stream labs too
yeah hold on let me get the [ __ ] draw
out
so i can highlight them well no i see
them
yeah i mean i you don't need to draw i i
see them so her whole point was that
this is part of her point
that i was making money off of her and
be honest with you i would make
the same amount of money whether i
talked about you or whether i talked
about [ __ ] uh
tom of [ __ ] thomas all day you're
you're skipping a few
there bud yeah yeah i was i know i
wasn't going there i was actually doing
this oh all right yeah
i'm sorry i had him out of order uh see
this happens when you put 87
[ __ ] tabs up there and you don't know
bro it's more than 87.
um which one which one
which one do we want to do because it's
a mess
yeah i think the [ __ ] day way hold it
yeah the [ __ ] day wait let's start there
because that really explains it all um
but then again you've you've done the
exploiting show
i'm looking at getting a lawyer i guess
okay uh blackmailing me now yeah i'm
calling the lawyers is calling the
lawyers is exhausting
or i'm looking at getting a lawyer i'm
looking at getting all right you're
right let's do that
please i need a lawyer
because i can't i can't do it anymore
they're lying about
me they're talking about they're
blackmailing me they're telling me what
i'm allowed to say on my channel what
i'm not allowed to talk about
i want to address something okay so
she's
really mad that we've called her a duck
murderer
now i'm gonna explain why this bit
works um and look all right
fourth wall down okay ladies and
gentlemen
oh no that was a structural wall it's
coming down around us jj
[ __ ] stop putting the repair tool up
and repairing what i'm trying to tear
down the royce
put the cheat sword away you've
destroyed the house no i do i only do
smelters and then make friends
[Laughter]
oh but she's mad that we called her duck
murderer and here's the thing
all right sometimes in this business
you make claims that you know
damn well uh aren't
factual like 100 factual they are built
upon
possibilities but they're still not
factual
in the end it does not matter you still
just run with the bit right
yeah that's what i do so do i think
she's a duck murderer
no no no no no is it funny as hell to
trigger her with it oh [ __ ] yes
yes yes yes hurting me without them
attacking me
they want to talk about liable they went
on their channel
for seven thousand subscribers in
college a-a-a-a seven thousand
six hundred and sixty i can't wait till
she see
that she doesn't even know about rotc
that's the fun part and then
wait till ap like ladies and gentlemen
tonight make sure you tune in to adonis
paul's yeah i would definitely recommend
it oh god it's gonna be [ __ ]
fantastic
yeah murderer and an accomplice to
murder and said that they knew it for a
fact because they read the book
they are definitely
i need a lawyer i'm going to buy a gun
i'm going to buy a gun and rent a bullet
please probably tomorrow because it's
raining today but
i'm going to be looking into an actual
lawsuit against these people because now
they're trying to manipulate and control
me and blackmail me
and tell me what i'm allowed to talk
about it on my channel
so let me again i i really want to point
something out when it comes to this
video
nobody's blackmailing almost
manipulating her i said i'm gonna
i'll tell you what i'm gonna stop
talking about you you stop talking about
me we'll move on and i really meant that
i was going to move on i was going to
stop talking about her
and when i put all i posted in the
comments i wasn't even being mean i said
look i'm going to stop talking about you
i'm actually done
you know you honestly should really get
some help and i did post a suicide
hotline i go
seriously you seem to be [ __ ] up get
some help i go look i'll stop talking
about you you stop talking about me and
then she got mad you was i'm gonna talk
about whatever the [ __ ] i want
don't tell me who the [ __ ] i could talk
about [ __ ]
you don't tell me what to do goddammit
man
yeah she was like don't tell me what to
do i could talk about whatever i want
and i'm like
um this is what she wrote in response to
that
saying that if it was explained to me
that if i do this you'll leave me alone
it makes it feel like you're holding me
captive you're telling me what i'm
allowed to put on
my channel and not be pushed myself
you're telling me well if you just play
pokemon so no what she wants to do is
she wants to be able to talk about me
but no one's allowed to talk about her
well that's the problem that's the issue
yeah
we'll let you live but if you keep
talking about your life and the things
that bother you
we're going to push you to yourself and
that nobody
she's this is the problem with her she's
lying
now she says that i'm a liar okay i'm
gonna call you a liar now
that is a [ __ ] lie you're lying
you're lying you're lying you're lying
that's not true
and that's just how it is and it's your
own fault because we told you what you
could legally do
without being pushed to hurt yourself
that's [ __ ]
i'm a human being i should be allowed to
speak my mind and talk about
things that i need to talk about without
people like you
making money off of it and pushing me
did you catch that little last part
there ladies and gentlemen what was that
last part
it's making money off of it
making money off of it now if you heard
her say that she her
on her channel she's allowed to say her
opinion and no one's allowed to tell her
otherwise
why don't you get that applied to you
why are you not allowed to comment on
whatever you want
why is it always a one-way street with
these people
i get this i get this you don't and here
we are
so that's where we are there and then um
let's see because some of these some of
these aren't
some worth playing some aren't yeah uh
legal aid yeah legal aid is worth it yes
you're right yes
i just got off of the phone with legal
aid and
they're saying they're not sure what um
they can do unless i get a
civil harassment lawsuit
and from what i'm telling them it sounds
like they're threatening me and that i
should
no one's threatened her not once my next
call
and and there's several messages of my
youtube channel saying look we're going
to leave you alone and
all i've said is get help and when i say
get helps you replies don't tell me what
she actually commented don't tell me
what to do
and all i said was lady please get help
i'm gonna leave you alone
you leave me alone we'll leave each
other alone and we'll just move on and i
really meant that that wasn't a bit
like that was me honestly saying i'm
gonna leave it alone but then you know
well you'll see there there's a whole
thing there's a whole story line coming
along with us
it's so good to make an actual report
of harassment and then from there
i'll figure out how to get a lawyer to
file a civil suit
on the blackmail well excuse me i'm a
cuban male
so let's [ __ ] get that straight right
i'm white everybody hates me now so i
don't you know i'm not a black male
so um the next video that i want to play
i could skip calling lawyers as mentally
exhausted we did yeah
that's not worth playing my channel was
never about the views dad that's not
really
that's not really worth playing uh
this one is pawn shops pawn shops
don't bite me don't take microwaves
anymore
i walked all the way down here with dope
and i could get just
five dollars to get something to eat oh
don't worry daddy fix that
well ladies and gentlemen pawn shops
don't take microwaves anymore the best
sound drop of the day right there but
it's true but you know what
uh it's true they don't
i wonder why maybe because they give
them out free and then all the
like oh you give me five bucks for this
literally brand new in the box and the
punch-up wouldn't look at me
i just wanted to get something to eat i
still have three days until my funds
come in
these guys have been pushing me to where
i've been eating gluten and making
myself sick
that's our fault too yep she's eating
pizza ladies and gentlemen we forced
a woman to eat pizza
and no i can't get anything
i can't even sell what i have because
nobody wants it even though it's a
perfectly good microwave
they act like nobody uses microwaves
anymore
so i'm just i'm just thinking so she had
the microwave it didn't work
doesn't she have the controller like
that's got to be no no no no you gotta
play pokemon dude
i mean i get that but like
so in the comments of that video
in the in the comment of that video
i uh
hold on let me about to pull up the
right one all right here it is and this
one has the aps in this screenshot too
in the comment of that video
and i did this and i'm going to show you
that i did this i'm not i'm not yeah i'm
not on a lie i'm not a liar
i wrote i just sent you 50 for the right
to play your videos until the end of
time
if you don't agree i can refund please
let me know
uh and then ap and for the payoff for
the aps you're gonna have to watch a
show tonight i'll send you five bucks on
paypal
but you gotta make a video singing i'm a
little teapot song so
that's something different but that's
not that's not mine
hey look [ __ ] adonis paul that's
harassment okay
yeah how dare you five dollars to an
obviously mentally ill person and get
them to sing a song what in the hell
is wrong with your big nibble brain so
what i did was as you could see here and
this is just to show you a fifty dollars
paypal i sent it to her from day wave
radio royce for the right to play your
videos from now until the end of time
i mean this seems like a deal to me and
there it is so you can see that i sent
it you've sent
50 okay i i sent her 50
[ __ ] dollars all right
so because we always knew it was about
the money and of course she says
fifty dollars for the videos yes or no
should i refund that
she says and as you can see here as you
can see here
she says use
the videos that that's a legal document
right there now and not only and not
only does you say lose the videos
you've abused the videos updated on what
was going on
royce from dave wave sent me 50 dollars
for permission
to exploit my videos for the rest of my
life which
you know he's gonna be doing it anyways
fine at least i got something out of it
but
what bothers me is that they lie
it wouldn't bother me so much if they
were just watching my videos what
bothers me if they
lie about it but it doesn't matter you
said yes
we said it looked like ringworm yeah
look okay look i was a wrestling referee
i saw a lot of ringworm in my life those
are not ant bites that's ringworm
okay i'm telling you i'm not a doctor
but i've seen ringworm several [ __ ]
times
that is ringworm if you don't treat it
it's gonna get bigger
you guys still feel bad for her i'm a
murderer
sending people to my channel to call me
a murderer
nobody did that all right no no no no
one sent
things to your channel but i always said
alleged accessory to murder not murderer
but i did say
duck murderer but that uh in a court of
law
any plain normal person would understand
that i am completely joking that you
murdered ducks with rice
now i want to say this now she was able
to eat
but a lot of you fell for it a lot of
you were like leave her alone she's
really messed up man lucas is really
messed up we're like she's not really
that messed up
there's more this is more this is about
something else this is about money this
is about attention
and it turns out there's money this is
about money this is about attention
this is what this was always about well
don't forget her
alt accounts that were trying to argue
with people in her youtube comments yeah
i know they were
and actually one of her friends quote
unquote says you should have asked for
more and i go look i could take the
money back and not talk about her i have
no issue
there's like no no no it's fine it's
fine it's fine yeah
they backtracked that real quick she
[ __ ] up once and said i
in one of her things too so it was like
lady i don't think you understand how
long both of us have been doing this and
messing with internet people
and none of your little [ __ ] uh
gypsy tricks are gonna work
so uh look there's a little bit more of
this we're gonna play some more videos
of her today because i do have some
stuff
uh but but
i will say that there is a listen to
adonis paul tonight if you if you're not
watching the show
can i'm going to say this it's
criminally under sub show
adonis apostles criminally undersubbed
it's it's a fantastic show what he does
is great he's hilarious
i like him he makes all of our
production look like [ __ ]
kindergarten shows right he makes us
look like [ __ ] [ __ ]
and um look the fact that he put it to
this way even though he cheated in the
save by the bell contest
is doesn't matter to me and also he
wants to do a beavis and butthead
contest i really didn't watch he wasn't
butted so pick something else
okay but but the thing is he didn't
cheat though royce like
if anything you were given points to
catch up because it was painfully
obvious that you were losing in the
first and second round very badly
jj whose side are you on here i'm look
i'm on the side of truth and justice i'm
kind of like the shield
i just come in from the crowd i [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and i will represent
you roman reigns you [ __ ] dick
yeah it does make you roman reigns you
both have blood cancer um
all right god damn it hey hey
and the sad thing is i'm a kind of
[ __ ] like in a way dude kind of look
like him
yeah he threw it up there for me i had
to hit it i know
i gave you a softball yeah
so um
this one is um
this one is uh contemplating new
medications she's contemplating them
which is great so pokemon is uploading
good good
my lazy eyes wandering so i am uh gonna
try to sleep
and ignore that look there's a stroke in
there somewhere hey hey hey
hey i got something for you uh can you
do me a favor
sure okay just let uh i'm gonna send you
something right now
sure okay um it's gonna be a picture
okay and i need you to uh add it to the
uh
to the screen and uh place it upon her
head if you can
all right all right you know what
you you're a piece of [ __ ] you know that
god damn it all right give me give me a
sec
give me a second hey i got something
else for you too hold on you gonna need
it because i thought about it
hold on you're gonna take me another
second to find it no i gotta add it
yeah yeah it's okay by the time i get
around to it
yeah there it is all right here's the
other one because you're going to need
it
it's lacking but it'll be fine here in a
second
all right so now i have to
[Music]
see where i save it shout out to dustin
tv in the chat what's up big man
i'll do chat work uh jason fritz mrs
effect lives
uh the one-eyed symbolism from dorothy
the hands of george the animal steel
all right there it is
there it is he did it yeah yeah but
there's there's
it's it's still missing something rush
okay hold on
let me see you're such a dick
oh come on man
hold on i gotta save it now
now all right here's the bit though
cause like you just go ahead and leave
that
in the uh obs and then any time that you
see it
and you notice it it's called the mercer
effect ah you're such a dick
um the true mercer effect it's the one
that actually makes sense
it's not like a forced bit that you
can't get over but you still need 30
some people to help
ah let's see here i'm coming sorry
all right let me out let me at this one
royce is like you're causing problems
with me shut up
no no i was actually no i was i wasn't i
was just focusing on the uh
on yeah the overlay all right
okay there we go here we go
you [ __ ] [ __ ] do you know how long
i've been doing that
oh [ __ ] man hey we're not lying right
now
let's see um if i can i've been having a
lot of
trouble sleeping recently
there it is there's a screenshot of
someone wanting so
accurate
[Laughter]
every time i look at it i crack up again
oh [ __ ] man
oh man all right all right it's over
[Laughter]
okay let me let me actually move them
down
we'll just hide them that's what i'm
doing that's what i'm doing yeah then
you can just put them back up but
anytime you see one that looks like hey
do you need the other one too just in
case you see yourself yeah send it
that's fine i don't mind
you know i don't care i know you take
you're you're pretty good at taking two
the other one not so much but it's okay
we're used to it
all right well work is to it the world
isn't yet all right
there we go all right i got it
just um oh sorry let's start it again
people weren't focusing we had to start
the video again
my lazy eyes wandering so i am going to
try to sleep
and ignore that sorry um if i can i've
been having
a lot of trouble sleeping recently
i've been having nightmares and waking
up and
just um when i went to the doctor on
tuesday he talked about putting me back
i don't know if you all remember oh yeah
uh
yeah fix that because he's look he's
he's one of the top well
but give me let me make sure it's him
because
uh i mean i understand what you're
saying
yeah you know what i'll find out right
now you have to vet them
okay and and people do all right people
do be doing that no man's sam spoof [ __ ]
so i get it
yeah uh oh
[Music]
[Applause]
adonis paul this is what she gets we're
selling out
uh nikki fruity uh loops i have rice
cooker too but can't ever invest time to
cook
like the crock pot one day though hey
dustin
check your facebook get an air fryer uh
michael b this guy changed my oil last
week possible
kind of look kind of just look like
somebody somebody in a [ __ ] jiffy
loop
remember when i was on the pros ace and
i didn't take it for very long uh
what it is is a blood pressure
medication that is
often prescribed to people with ptsd
because it helps suppress dreams
but because it's a blood pressure
medication it makes you feel really
funky
and i couldn't do it okay hold on man
all right look guys when you're taking
medication again i'm on medication
because i got a lot of problems
but when you start the medications for
two weeks it's gonna be weird because
you're taking something new
okay right so you have to like get used
to what you're taking
uh drew smith says i'm blocked for
reasons i have no clue never said the n
word wants bummers i have no idea i
didn't block i haven't i don't i
i rarely block people on here so that's
that's something that
unless you're being a real [ __ ] idiot
like merch yells at you if you don't
block enough people
royce yells at you if you block anyone
yeah i'm not a big i i mean i will don't
get me wrong like spam or like [ __ ]
being spurgs or personal [ __ ]
like personally like post pers i always
block that but i really don't
normally block a lot of people ever yeah
with it so i'd rather deal with the
dreams but
if um after like this week i can't deal
with the dreams anymore my message get
deleted oh no no that that's been
happening to me
even me and other people i don't know
what's going on and i'm sorry i mean
josh you're relaxed um for whatever
reason
lately i've been getting a bunch of
messages people saying message deleted
or google
google team has deleted your messages i
don't know what they're they're [ __ ]
with something in the algorithm lately
but it's been happening to a lot of
people yeah that auto mods are sunbitch
yeah or i might go back
and ask for the prosacen my doctor's
only in on
tuesdays so is it is it pepper
or dre
i have to make up my mind i'm gonna do
the old shot it's a doctor hook
hey dr hook is
before tuesday and then i can do a
walk-in on tuesday and ask him to get it
for me but
i'm trying really hard to get through
the rest of this month
without needing anything extra
um i didn't need the prozac in last
march
but i'm i'm i'm really trying not not to
need it this month
i'm
it's hard cause i've got so much going
on
i'm sorry how many things do you have
going on
okay so we have she just uh left a
microwave at a pawn shop
uh she has two fat bearded men [ __ ]
with her on the internet
uh several years ago she was
involved in an alleged uh accessory to
murder
uh for uh for burying a
i can't i don't i want to watch out
because she'll say if you miss one
little thing she'll say you're lying
i don't remember what the lady i think
it was cerebral palsy
um and then she waited five weeks to
for let me ask you something if someone
let's say
uh adonis paul comes by stun guns you
like scott hall
right and and then takes you
to the bowels of the pleasure palace
right
and holds you captive for five weeks
you were involved and you saw him
torture other people in front of you
so you're scared i get it
but do you think five weeks four
weeks and one week uh is
is enough time to try and get out like
would you try and get out or would you
wait
um i would probably try to get out
immediately why would you wait right
yeah and i'm not saying that she she
waited on purpose i get that
but i find it hard to believe that she
did not have opportunity and look
this is pure speculation i'm not lying
i'm just speculating here
um but i find it hard to believe that
five weeks
by before you know and look mary this is
why we want to
call and ask you because i'm pretty sure
there's an answer to this question
don't be scared of us okay we're not
here to ruin your life we're just here
to help you get a bigger channel because
we noticed something deep down inside
you
you are a content machine
and we want to help you flourish i can't
deal with the dream i backed up a bit
because
i missed that i might go back and ask
for the prosacen
my doctor's only in on tuesdays so
i have to make up my mind before tuesday
and then i can do a walk-in on tuesday
and ask him to get it for me but
i'm trying really hard to get through
the rest of this month
without needing anything extra
um i did need the prosacen last march
but i'm i'm i'm really trying not not to
need it this month
i'm
it's hard because i've got so much going
on
i've been watching arthur to try to take
my mind off of everything else
when i'm not playing pokemon hey hey
nerds
nerds can i please get the arthur mean
with her
can can one of y'all go through her
videos and find a clenched fist
like with her with her crappy nails and
ho the hobo nails
and like do the arthur thing with the
thing put her fist you understand what
i'm saying nerds
oh i see i i hear what you're saying
yeah
hey by the way dustin tv wants uh to
know if he can put a link in the chat i
just did it form certainly yeah of
course
chill away sir yeah of course
or freaking out on y'all
i um i have actually been doing
something
to try to calm myself down which is i
downloaded a whole bunch of
first season arthur episodes
that i've been rewatching just
it's a comfort show for me it's stupid
but
it it helps me i don't know feel like
things are less crazy than they are i
feel like scuffing
patty needs to watch some doug too
yeah probably some doug maybe even ren
and stimpy
yes
um character was drawn much
cuter in the first season than in the
rest of the season i don't know
she likes being drunk she likes drawings
she does
man adonis paul tonight at midnight
ladies and gentlemen come to the
pleasure palace and watch a
nice documentary mm-hmm rocumentary
yeah hobo entry anybody else noticed
that like
in the first couple episodes she had
this uh overbite
that was adorable yeah well okay
whatever i don't care
um come on i paid you for these videos i
need good videos
did she have man cheekbones too yeah i i
i paid good money for these videos i
want good videos you know
hey hey she's trying is she